this whole thing about abundance and
attracting to yourself what it is that
you want and how to use mantras and
spirituality to make sure you have what
you want true spirituality is about not
wanting is about being filled with joy
from inside and then sharing that
outside it's not about attracting to
yourself what you want people ask me is
there a law of attraction yes and you
better be scared of it because if it's
true that you attract what your mind is
thinking you better take a look at what
your mind is thinking what about your
mind all day when it's complaining and
it's yelling at people and it doesn't
like stuff but if you're attracting that
way so you eventually catch on that it
is not about getting what you want it is
about learning to find out that what you
really want is to stay open and not have
conditions on that openness and then it
comes down to how do you do that are
people capable of doing that or is that
just reserved for you know some special
beings Buddha and Christ that have
walked the face of the Earth everybody
is capable of that if I tell you to pick
up five thousand pounds you may not be
able to do that so I've told you to do
something that you have never done and
you're not doing it so you may not be
able to do it but if you're actually
already doing something and I tell you
not to do it you're always capable of
that because you're the one who's doing
it hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because as a young
entrepreneur I struggle to keep my
business going I had no friends I had no
mentors I had no role models and the
thing that saved me was learning from
the success stories of famous
entrepreneurs and in their stories I got
motivation and I also got strategies for
what I could do to grow my business and
not stay stuck and I still need their
stories motivation today so today let's
learn how to master the art of
manifestation enjoy
so inside you are the one who's closing
your heart you close it you are the one
who's closing your mind you do that
they're your thoughts it's your feelings
they're nobody else's so you are in
there doing these things so if I tell
you the way to stay open is to not close
I don't teach how to stay open that's
more like finding out how to get what
you want I'm interested in you learning
to not close but a difference if I say
to you I want you to open your heart
right now you wouldn't even know how to
start
but if I say to you somebody says and
you don't like don't close you know
where to start right because it's
happening inside of you and you see the
tendency to do it all I'm asking you to
do is don't do that I'm telling you that
will take you the whole way don't worry
about opening worry about not closing
there are going to be events that unfold
in your life that naturally open you a
beautiful sunset a bird singing
sometimes you get what your mind wants
all right you open great nothing wrong
with that don't close
how come it only last a minute I'm going
to see a beautiful sunset you feel like
oh my God I looked in the face of God
then you go right back into your mind
with all your problems why
why don't you learn to not close why
don't you get some openness start to
work with yourself to not close and this
is how to get what you really want the
teeth the Deep spiritual teachings are
really teaching you how to get what you
want because what you want is to feel
love and joy and happiness all the time
and so if you can get that from within
you then can share it rule number two is
invest in productive Thoughts with Bruce
Lipton money is the equivalent of energy
so you can buy energy with your cash and
the significance about that is if you're
Frugal and take care of your money and
keep a balance then you always have this
energy in your bank account energy in
which you can live however obviously if
you waste this energy then you actually
interfere with your own Survival so you
don't really want to go out and just
throw away your money and so basically I
really want to show you that this is an
important insight into the nature of our
own health and our biology and the world
we create in this regard that our
biological system the cells rely on
energy without energy there's no life so
fundamentally you have an energy budget
that gives you life and in fact in the
body energy is in coins called ATP
molecules that represent units of energy
so in fact biologists refer to ATP as
the coin of the red realm the
significance of ATP is this is that ATP
molecules are like units of gasoline
like gallon of gas that are used to fuel
our biological processes so to stay
alive we have to have all this ATP so
there's an ATP account in your body
right now but the question is how do you
use this ATP and now here's an important
fact that 25 percent of the total energy
in your whole body is used to operate
your brain so all of a sudden you start
to recognize that the brain uses energy
at the rate of muscles of a marathon
runner so a brain and muscle activity
are pretty much the same and so why is
this important because as you're using
your brain as you're using your thinking
you are actually using energy now why is
this relevant the answer is very simply
this because the way we've been using
our thoughts are not necessarily
productive a matter of fact sometimes
our investments of our thoughts are
actually counterproductive because our
thoughts create a reality that we then
have to overcome so basically it says
that we must start to become aware of
our thoughts and why is this important
because thoughts represent units of
energy every time you have a thought you
use energy why this becomes relevant is
if I give you a checkbook for your bank
account you don't go down the street and
just write checks to people like oh hey
you're a nice looking guy here's 10
bucks for you and oh here little girl go
out and buy yourself a little car here's
a thousand dollars for you and you don't
give away your money why because giving
away your money is giving away your life
so basically you become very frugal when
you have a checkbook in your hand now
what I'm trying to tell you is this you
have an energy budget in your body the
energy is what keeps you alive when you
start using energy and writing checks
where you get no return from your energy
then it's exactly the same as writing
checks out of your bank checkbook and
giving away your cash so why this
becomes important is the biology of
belief
reveals how our thoughts create our
reality and if you start investing in
thoughts that are counterproductive
thoughts like fear or what am I going to
do and how am I going to escape this
problem or how is this going to go wrong
and all these other kinds of thoughts
that are negative kinds of thoughts then
realize this you are actually not just
using your energy for having these
thoughts but these thoughts are also
what come into your reality what you
focus on with your thoughts your brain
will manifest as reality everything you
do in your life you put out energy for
therefore start to review what you're
doing in your life because if you're
putting your energy into things you
cannot change in this world that is
exactly the same as writing a check and
just throwing away your money to the
outside because you get nothing back
from it so think about this very
interesting reality that you have this
energy checkbook and every time you use
energy you have to say is the use of
this energy
going to enhance my life or is it just
wasted energy am I getting involved in a
political argument with people where I'm
going to use up all my energy and will I
have changed the world no
am I going to use up all my energy to
try to convince other people to change
their life or change their way of living
to make them even healthier and they're
not ready to do that I'd be wasting my
energy
so here's an interesting thought
if I gave you an energy checkbook and
asked you to write a check every time
you had to have a thought you would have
to then ask yourself is is this thought
going to enhance my life or is this
thought going to take away from my life
and then when you start to realize that
you start to direct your actions where
you put your energy into things that
enhance your life and give you an
opportunity to survive and to go Beyond
Survival and really into thriving
so the point is this we are facing some
rough times the more thoughts you put
into the negative aspect the more
thoughts you put into the fear not only
are you just wasting your energy but as
in the biology belief these negative
thoughts these negative stresses
actually impair your immune system and
bring on disease itself rule number
three is practice proper manifestation
with Mel Robbins manifesting is
intentionally
training your brain and your nervous
system to believe in something that
hasn't happened yet that's what
manifesting is manifesting is a power
tool it's backed by Neuroscience it is
backed by years of research and when
used properly
it helps you achieve your goals because
it helps you prepare to do the work I
use
science-backed manifesting tools every
single day to shut down the negative
conversations in my life and to live a
big life and to take big risks and dude
Olympic athletes use manifesting and
we're going to get into how Olympic
athletes and the world's leading you
know Business Leaders and successful
people everywhere use it but I'm telling
you right now the way you shut down your
internal
conversation that is holding you back is
manifesting manifesting is one of the
first things you have to learn how to do
to get started on making this a reality
so what is manifesting manifesting is
mentally training
forgetting what you want that's all that
it is it is part of the toolkit that
successful people around the world use
let me tell you what manifesting is not
manifesting is not thinking thoughts and
then hoping they come through
that is what people do on their seventh
birthday and they blow out the candles
that is not what we are doing here
manifesting is based in neuroscience
it is a tool that you are going to use
precisely intentionally systematically
with purpose
because you use manifesting to re-wire
your mind and your body and your spirit
to help you do the work to achieve your
dreams
when you use manifesting properly
you are removing the mental obstacles of
self-doubt resistance fear perfectionism
feeling overwhelmed other people's
expectations all that stuff that is
holding you in place right now that
makes you spin in circles manifest and
clears that out and it programs
using science a completely different way
of thinking and feeling about the things
that you want to create in your life and
when you manifest properly it's almost
like the pregame training that you do
before the big game It prepares you to
take action it boosts your confidence it
gets you ready to do that thing also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is create vision
boards with Dr Power sword I'll start
with visualization
um and vision boards I kind of the
science behind them is is quite similar
so it's basically about three processes
that happen in the brain and they are
selective filtering selective attention
and value tagging
so basically we're bombarded with so
much information and this has been the
case for a long time but if you read a
copy of the New York Times today
you would receive as much information
from that one newspaper as somebody
would in their entire lifetime 100 years
ago and even then they were overly
bombarded with information so the brain
has a natural
um filtering mechanism which is that you
don't have need to notice things that
aren't really relevant to your survival
so for example you don't notice your
clothes on your body all day
um so we need to direct that filtering
system otherwise
in a way we're still wired just to
survive and reproduce
so things that will help us to thrive in
the modern world may not necessarily be
filtered in unless we're presenting
visual images to our brain on a daily
basis or sitting down and closing our
eyes and you know visualizing the things
that we want in our life for a certain
outcome if we do those practices
then the next process comes in which is
selective attention which is that you
notice the things that you're
visualizing or you have on your vision
board it's like when you buy a new car
and then you suddenly see it everywhere
um so it's basically priming your brain
to notice opportunities that will take
you closer to your goals and then value
tagging is the brain's system of putting
things in order of importance and it
does this in two ways it does it in a
cold or logical way under warm or
emotional way so The Logical things are
basically the survival you know the
basics that we need to survive like roof
over our head food on the table
um and the warmer things are the ones
that we might choose to put on our
vision board so they're the things you
know our dreams our desires goals that
show that we're thriving rather than
just kind of you know surviving
so by repeatedly exposing your brain to
these images you're priming it to not
just notice but also grasp the
opportunities that will take you closer
to what you want and that's why I call
vision boards action boards because I
don't believe that you can create this
fantasy image and sit at home and wait
for it to come true I believe that you
need to be out there networking dating
whatever it is
um to get the things that you want rule
number five is seek fulfillment with
Eckhart Tolle to go about wanting to
manifest material abundance in your life
is perhaps not the
the right way to go about it
because you're concentrating on the
outermost layer of abundance
and even if you manage to manifest
abundance on the outer level
it's not going to give you the true
feeling of abundance it's not in other
words it's not going to make you happy
it's not going to fulfill you except for
a few days
the new possession nice and shiny
whatever it is and there you look at it
got it now it's mine
and after a few days or a week or two
or give it to months
it wears off hmm
it's no longer that fulfilling to be
driving the Ferrari or whatever it is
there's nothing wrong with the Ferrari
but if you're looking to the Ferrari for
happiness and fulfillment and to get you
give you the feeling of
it's not going to work for that long
if you're just driving it because you
enjoy that experience it's a different
matter manifest abundance From the
Inside Out not from the outside is
hoping that you go
find some Interstate through external
things
that is the Dilemma of many people who
practice manifesting
which of course manifesting is a
something that
you can use
and it works if it's done rightly
but the Dilemma or the fallacy is
the belief that whatever you manifest
is going to make you happy
it's to seek
the fullness of life through what you
manifest
through things rule number six is build
a miracle mindset with Gabby Bernstein I
think that there's this really cool
quote from this metaphysical text that
Miracles are natural but when they're
not occurring something has gone wrong
so I think that we all are living in
this way where we're just consistently
blocking the miraculous because we build
up a belief system that is very worldly
it's fear it's trauma it's
disconnection and of course we have so
many different outside influences that
would take us away from that Miracle
mindset but the beauty is is that as we
start to read books like super attractor
listen to interviews like this and just
start to slightly adjust and adjust and
adjust back into that Miracle mindset we
can return to something that never left
us it's just it's been blocked and is
the miracle mindset what you talk about
when you say getting back to the truth
of who you are yeah I I believe that we
all have the capacity to live in the
world with a positive solution seeking
sense of support energetic support and
awareness of of a spiritual connection
Beyond us a spiritual connection of your
own whatever you decided to be
but like I said we're in this constant
struggle of the problems the war the the
divisiveness the whatever it might be
the bullying the every single moment of
life is a almost taking us away from the
truth to your point the truth of who we
are and that truth of who we are is very
simple it's that we are in our hearts
compassionate caring calm just
absolutely loving beings every single
person but many of us have experiences
that make us detour from that space and
rule number seven the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is think
effortlessly with Rhonda Byrne I want to
just tell you about manifestation
because it's effortless okay it's light
and it's effortless there's no effort
involved when you're fighting when
you're pushing you don't believe that
you have what you're wanting it's not
going to come you're going to keep
creating not having it because you're
creating all the time so you either
manifesting it or you're creating not
manifesting it or the absence that's all
but so
um so manifestation is like like I once
used to think that it um that it's as
light as a feather so there's this
effortless feeling that you have inside
of you when you want to manifest it's
just like this
feeling of peace and happiness and you
just know that it's going to come and
you know that a single thought that you
focus on will manifest
um you have
all power to manifest whatever you want
all power
and so if you don't believe in the power
that you have then you're going to
really push and push and pull and fight
so no fighting
positive mantras don't work and they
don't work because people pick positive
mantras that they don't believe so if
you are in a studio apartment eating
rice and beans barely able to pay your
bills Stan standing in front of a mirror
and saying I'm a millionaire I'm going
to be a millionaire someday what happens
based on Research is your brain's like
uh actually have you seen where you live
like have you seen that you've quit
every job that you've had your brain has
a great detector the mistake people make
is they pick a mantra that is the exact
opposite of the way they treat
themselves it wants action
behavioral activation therapy act like
the person you say you want to be and
then maybe I'll believe you you know
instead of I love my body after trashing
your body for 20 years say I deserve to
be healthy even if you hate your body
anybody and any brain can get behind
yeah you do that's right I'm glad you're
waking up you do deserve to be healthy
now prove it let's take some actions
that show you that so no mantras don't
work if you're picking a mantra you
don't believe and if you're picking a
mantra that is the opposite of the way
you treat yourself and the actions you
take so that's number one number two
manifesting everybody has been sold a
bill of goods about manifesting
if you make a vision board with your uh
house on the ocean or you at the stock
exchange ringing the bell and that's all
that you have on it
science says that that vision board will
become a source of
profound discouragement
because over time as you sit there and
stare at your dream house or you ringing
the bell at NASDAQ and nothing in your
life changes
you start to feel further and further
and further away from what you want
which makes you feel further and further
discouraged which means you're less and
less motivated to even begin working on
it like the hardest part for everybody
is to start and the reason why is not
only the patterns of procrastination and
anxiety and stuff that you get trapped
in but it's also because your goals feel
so far away that you don't believe that
just starting is going to even chip away
at it and so number one because it
sounds like I just contradicted myself
yes you need to have something like a
beach house or the NASDAQ Bell or the
business you're starting or the love
affair of your life or the family you've
always envisioned or the health that
you've always dreamed about
absolutely swing for the fences what do
you want it to look like 10 years from
now
but when it comes to manifesting based
on science I want you to think as
manifesting as a bridge
manifesting is a bridge that's made of
bricks
between you
and the thing that you dream about
and what you do when you manifest is you
don't manifest where the bridge is going
you manifest the bricks
so a great example is a marathon so
let's say that you've never run a day in
your life but your bucket list is to
complete the London Marathon
yes you can put on your vision board
a photograph of a runner crossing the
London Marathon you can even put the
dream that you have in terms of the the
number that you want the time to be okay
but you better put a runner in the rain
up there
you better put an alarm clock that says
4 30 in the morning because that's what
time you're going to have to get up in
order to get your training runs in you
better put a runner that's gripping
their leg like this when they get a
muscle cramp you better put up uh you
know a vision of you at Mile 13 and your
earbuds run out and you still got two
more miles to go
visualization is the bricks and so what
I want you to do when you visualize is
instead of visualizing ah the marathon I
did it I was amazing and then you open
up you're like okay and I still have not
even bought a pair of sneakers
that's not happening but that was a fun
little exercise no what you do is you
literally visualize walk into the store
and get sneakers
call your friend who runs and ask for
advice
oh my God that's me on my first training
run I've only gone 30 seconds and I'm
out of breath oh there I am running
three miles in the rain and I feel proud
of myself because I've actually gone out
in the rain oh there I am saying uh no
to my friends I can't go out tonight
because I didn't get my running but I'm
going to go on my big run alone that
like you visualize the annoying
irritating amazing things I'm sure
people look at you all the time with
your extraordinary success Steven and
are like how'd you do it how'd you do it
and
like do you know how many things I
missed out on do you know how many like
how like the amount of work that nobody
wants to do because they're not thinking
about it
is extraordinary that's the bridge
anybody is capable of achieving anything
I actually believe that because I think
human beings are designed to change
you're capable of breaking any pattern
you're capable of getting control of
your health you're capable of launching
a business you're capable of making
millions of dollars you're capable of
healing your trauma of finding love of
doing absolutely anything that you put
your mind to
as long as you are willing to do the
work for it and as long as you give up
your timeline
because I do believe
that people who put in the work get
rewarded
but you just might not get rewarded when
you think you're going to be and it
might not be the reward that you thought
you were gonna get is that the case in
your life it's always the case
and that's why I always have Big Dreams
because I have learned time and time and
time and time again especially in
entrepreneurial Ventures
that you put this huge flag out there
you write the business plan you set the
goals and then you put your head
down and you put in the work
and you ride the wave and you have the
disappointments and you spend the late
nights and you have the Heartbreak and
the heartache and then things change and
then you think this didn't work out
and I got betrayed and why didn't they
recognize me and damn it I've worked
hard and now I got to start all over and
you have all of that but if you keep
going
and you keep going
eventually you will look up one day and
be like holy
this
is exactly
what I was meant to do and what I was
meant to discover yeah my business plan
said I was supposed to go over here
and I ended up over here because this is
what I was supposed to do but without
this business plan I never would have
gotten started
the business plan was but a DOT on the
map of my life
connecting me to where I meant to go
you know I think one of the most
extraordinary things that has happened
to me in this past year especially now
that I have this real partnership with
myself
where I have a
level of trust
that through my attitude through my
actions through a sense of faith
that
it's going to turn out
that even when things are really hard I
still believe deep in my core
that through my attitude and my actions
it's going to be okay
that I have within me the power to ride
the ups and downs and to come out on the
other side of it
and
you know I think that we've all had the
experience Stephen of being able to look
backwards and say whoa you know I
wouldn't ever wish the experience that I
had back and forth grade on anybody
but without that experience
I would not be able to help the amount
of people that I help
I would not be able to understand trauma
as a lived experience and inside and out
and at a layer that's so deep because it
is an experience that I had in my life
without 25 years of struggling with
anxiety without having two kids that
have struggled with anxiety I would not
know what I know about anxiety and be
able to help people including my own
children
I would not without having made mistakes
with my kids and their anxiety be able
to tell parents do not do this because I
did this and it made my kids anxiety
worse and I didn't even know
and so I can see you know I can see how
everything from you know working as a
public defender to being a legal
commentator for CNN to the number of
stages that I've been on to the number
of people that I've helped I can see how
all of that comes together
to help me do what I need to do in this
moment
and I think one of the most powerful
things that you can cultivate when you
cultivate partnership with yourself
is being able every single day to have a
level of trust in your life
in the magic of things in yourself to
know that this moment right now is also
a DOT on the map of your life and 5 10
20 years from now you will look back on
this moment
and you will know exactly why this
happened
and why it happened is it was preparing
you for something
it was giving you a skill or an
experience or some wisdom or a
relationship that you're going to need
for something extraordinary that's
coming
and when you believe that it gives you
the strength to face absolutely anything
what's the difference between I guess
the still level of needing to master
your craft though right like you became
a great producer and a director and
creator that doesn't come after two days
of not working on your craft right
because you worked on your craft for a
decade or two until you had the skill
set the knowledge the wisdom to them
yeah put down what you needed to um
you're still doing things and it this is
the thing because if being effortless
doesn't mean you're not doing things
what it means is there's no effort in
what you're doing
so it's it's so you're still doing
things but it's effortless like you were
still working up but it was effortless
and so because the minute you feel like
you're struggling that's the mind and
that's the ego stepped in and then it's
not flowing you know and and people will
find when they're struggling you know
there's that goes wrong and then that
goes wrong and that goes wrong and so
you still do things and I still did all
of those things like before the secret I
did everything with effort full effort
one thousand percent hard work full
effort yeah total queen of effort
and you were lacking and you were
lacking abundance
you were lacking big results and yeah
yeah and so now I do like I I sat down
to do this book this book was absolutely
effortless really oh oh my gosh
absolutely and the most effortless book
that I have written for sure I mean
amazing really amazing and so when I was
writing the sea I wrote The Secret in
two and a half weeks two and a half
weeks because it just like
because I'd made the documentary I'd
done all these practices I knew what I
wanted to share all of the things that I
wanted to share in the secret and so I
mean we spent you know about six weeks
in the editing process of it but it just
came like a rush and that two and a half
weeks was effortless and when I did this
book it was effortless and I and there
have been books that I've gone to right
where has been a lot of effort really
you know yeah yeah and I and I just have
to stop because I remember I wrote a
book and I never published it and it was
all effort and it was enforcing it you
were yeah forcing it and so then what
you're writing about is you're just
writing a whole lot of recycled stuff
that the mind is turning up and you are
not receiving things from Beyond the
mind and you want to have things beyond
the mind
you know that's why when you when you're
an athlete and that flow and everything
that's because the mind is stopped it's
gone to the background and now you're
beyond the mind and when you're beyond
the mind oh anything's possible these
days of course everyone's talking about
intention fulfillment of Desire
uh manifestation
Etc so I thought I'd share with you what
uh some of the wisdom Traditions have
taught us about manifestation
and
from their teachings of non-duality we
can see that all manifestation is really
a differentiation of pure consciousness
which is infinitely creative
and is infinite and formless and
irreducible and
Timeless and spaceless and unimaginable
and inconceivable
but when intention is orchestrated from
that level
then it organizes its own fulfillment
that level is also called sankalpa
or a combination of dharana dhyan
samadhi but let me explain it in simple
English
so here are the six steps I think number
one a certain outcome is intended
number two the intention is specific and
definite
the person is certain about what he or
she wants
number three little or no attention is
paid to the details of the physiological
processes involved indeed paying
attention to the details inhibits the
flow of the impulses of intelligence
that produce the outcome slowing down or
preventing success
in other words the person takes an
attitude of non-interference nor
resistance to existence
number four the person expects a result
and has confidence in the outcome
there is no anxious attachment or
grasping to a result however if you are
anxious about falling asleep for example
that prevents the very outcome you
desire worry uncertainty and doubt are
the three primary obstacles that prevent
us from making
efficient use of the power contained in
sankalpa or intention the power is still
there but we turn it against itself when
we interfere in other words when you
doubt that a desire will come true
essentially you're sending out a
self-defeating intention which the field
computes field of Consciousness computes
is canceling out your first desire
number five there's a self-referring
feedback loop involved in other words
every fulfilled intention teaches you
how to fulfill the next intention even
better when the result occurs it
confirms the power of intention at a
conscious level
it increases confidence and makes
success stronger
okay so seed the intention water the
seed
and when the season is right the
intention will manifest and the effect
will be reinforcing
this change is doubt so when you do this
you know when you have sankalpan you
detach from the outcome this changes
doubt to certainty
people whose desires don't come true
also experience feedback but it
reinforces failure
okay so feedback
is always a result of
any intention whether it succeeds or not
will give you feedback and you'll notice
that
that intention if it doesn't succeed is
because of resistance to existence an
absence of flow
finally number six at the end of the
process there's no doubt that the
outcome was obtained by a definite
conscious process that extends beyond
the individual to a larger reality for
some this is God others Providence
but in the non-dual view it is the self
the absolute self
the absolute self not the self-image
so I try to use more scientific terms
and the one that I'm using right now is
the Consciousness field which is a
Consciousness energy field
but I don't think we should discard any
of the other more traditional spiritual
names in all cases the material world is
an expression of an unmanifest
overriding intelligence that responds to
human desire
the six steps that I just shared with
you are the most important
characteristic of inner intelligence it
has organizing power built into it
organizing power built into it the
organizing part is the link that
connects intention and result
without it there could be no cause or
effect
the quantum soup would remain chaotic
since without organizing part there can
be no patterns no orderliness no natural
laws no physical structures or
biochemical processes if you have a goal
you want to achieve in the year ahead or
if you find it hard to stay focused on
doing what you need to do to create the
life you want keep watching this video
because I'm about to share one of my
most powerful successful practices that
I have used to achieve my biggest goals
in life and if you commit to using this
practice every single day for the next
12 months I guarantee you will
experience huge shifts and you'll
achieve goals that you may not think are
possible right now and that success
practice is
drumroll
Daily Affirmations
now an affirmation as you probably
already know is a positive statement
that describes your goals as already
having been achieved it only takes a few
minutes but if you say your affirmation
out loud a few times every day with a
clear and focused mind while also
feeling the feelings you'd be feeling if
you'd already achieved that goal you'll
find it so much easier for you to keep
your goals top of mind and stay focused
and motivated as you work toward making
your dreams a reality so today I'd like
to teach you how to create your own
daily affirmation practice that you can
use to more effortlessly more quickly
and more efficiently accomplish your
goals and manifest your ideal vision of
the next 12 months ahead but first I'd
like to tell you about when I first
experienced the powerful the power of
affirmations in my life and when I was
in my 20s I had a mentor named Debbie
Clement Stone he was worth 600 million
dollars and he challenged me to set a
goal that was so far beyond my current
circumstances that it would literally
Astound me if I achieved it now I still
had a lot of self-esteem doubt back then
so it wasn't until a few years later
that I actually decided to put his
wisdom to the test I set myself the
challenge of making a jump from earning
around 25 000 a year to making a hundred
thousand a year or more the first thing
I did was to create an affirmation for
myself which went like this God is my
infinite Supply and large sums of money
come to me quickly and easily under the
grace of God is I'm happily and easily
earning spending and investing a hundred
thousand a year
next I created a huge replica of a
hundred thousand dollar bill which I
taped to the ceiling above my bed so
when I woke up every morning I would see
this hundred thousand dollar bill up
there and then immediately reminded me
to remember to repeat my affirmation to
myself and then I would visualize what I
would be enjoying if I were living a one
hundred thousand dollar a year lifestyle
I imagine the house I would live in the
artwork and the furniture that would be
there the car I would own the car I
would drive and what it would sound like
the vacations I would take and the
contributions of Charities I would make
I also Imagine the feelings I would
experience when I once I'd already
attained that lifestyle and you know
what not too long after that I woke up
one morning with my first hundred
thousand dollar idea I realized that if
I sold 400 000 copies of my book that
I'd written for teachers called 100 ways
to enhance self-confidence in the
classroom for which I earned a whole big
25 cents per book Realty I would earn a
hundred thousand dollar income so from
that point forward when I did my morning
affirmations and I also did it before I
went to bed at night I added the image
of my book flying off bookstore shelves
but see the whole window of a bookstore
filled with my books and I imagined the
publisher writing me a hundred thousand
dollar check now not long after a
freelance journalist approached me and
wrote an article about my work for the
National Enquirer and as a result
thousands of additional copies of my
book were sold that month and the money
making ideas just kept coming I took out
small ads and magazines and sold the
book on my own we started a little
bookstore so instead of 25 cents I'm
making three dollars a copy now I only
have to sell what 33 000 copies so
basically I'm selling this book then my
wife said you know we should sell other
books we started a little catalog so I
have my book of course we've made other
books and tapes and things that were
there back to the days of cassette tapes
and made even more money and then the
counseling department at the University
of Massachusetts where I was a graduate
student saw my catalog and invited me to
sell books at this weekend conference
they're putting on for school counselors
Book Sales that weekend generated more
than two thousand dollars in two days
and introduced me to another strategy I
could use to achieve my financial goal
which was to become a speaker and
conduct workshops and seminars just like
I seen at the conference and sell books
in the back of the room so I started the
book regular speaking and workshop gigs
and then I asked a friend who was doing
summer work at the time if I should
charge higher fees and he told me that
he was charging more than double what I
was being paid for the same work so I
followed this example I tripled my
speaking fees and a result of my book
sales and the income for my speaking
Goods my income that year skyrocketed
from 25
000 to over ninety two thousand now I
ended up missing my hundred thousand
dollar goal by almost eight thousand
dollars but I was still ecstatic I'd
almost quadrupled my income in less than
a year and I've made at least a
six-figure income often seven figure
income every year since then now that's
just one example of how I've used
affirmations to achieve my big goals in
life now working with affirmation has
also helped me get the idea for creating
a billion dollar brand writing a New
York Times number one best-selling book
actually about 47 of them and I now own
a vacation home in in about building one
in Costa Rica I owned one in Maui Hawaii
for a while I live in a 6 500 square
foot house in Santa Barbara So
affirmations are an extremely effective
way for you to align your subconscious
mind with the life you want to create
for yourself
so how do you create an affirmation when
you start with the vision of what you
want to be do or have in your life so
what I'd like you to do is to take a
moment close your eyes right now and
answer these questions or let an image
come into your awareness to answer the
question
so the question is what is your vision
for the next 12 months of your life
[Music]
what goals do you want to accomplish
what would your life look like and feel
like once those goals are accomplished
and allow yourself to sit in the
experience of that for a moment here you
are it's a year from now you've
accomplished all your goals and you're
feeling this the success of that the joy
of that the pride of that whatever it is
just for a moment visualize what that
life would look like
and what you would be feeling if you'd
already accomplished for me
foreign
[Music]
very good and once that vision is
clearly fixing your head go ahead and
open your eyes
and I want you to write down an
affirmation let me give you a little
look what I want
tutoring on how to do that it's
important to remember that it's a
positive statement that describes the
experience you'll enjoy once you're in a
state of already having accomplished
that so be sure to write it in the
present tense from the perspective of
your future self who've already achieved
that goal for example I'm so happy and
grateful now that I'm working in my
dream job and doing work I love is
making a positive impact in the world so
it starts with I am as you can see I'm
describing that experience in the
present tense it's describing what my
life will be like and how I will feel
once I achieve that ambitious goal so
what's the big goal that you want to
accomplish for your life in the next 12
months and how will you feel once you've
accomplished it maybe you'll feel happy
and grateful like me or maybe you'll
feel strong and confident or Blissful
and triumphant so choose two positive
and Powerful adjectives or feeling words
that will describe your state of being
once you've achieved that goal for your
life and then write your affirmation
something like this I am so whatever the
feeling is and the feeling is now that I
have and then you state the goal as if
you've already achieved it so the
example would be
you can maybe it goes to run a marathon
this year so your affirmation could be
I'm so happy and proud that I'm now
completing my first marathon in under
four hours so be sure to make it
specific and frame it as a positive
statement as opposed to a negative
statement for example I am so overjoyed
and grateful that I'm not in a bad
marriage anymore is not going to be good
because you've got the word bad marriage
in there because it's focused on what
you don't want which is a bad marriage
so make sure stated positively for
example I'm so overjoyed and grateful
that I'm now experiencing a healthy and
loving relationship with someone who
deeply appreciates me for who I am
all right so I encourage you to write an
affirmation like this for every Big Goal
you have for yourself this year and then
repeat each of them to yourself out loud
every morning and do it again right
before you go to bed
then after you've finished your
affirmation you've said them maybe you
have three four or five of them close
your eyes and visualize yourself
experiencing the very reality you've
just describing and see the scene as if
you're looking out through your eyes as
if you're actually living in it don't
see you out there you're looking out at
the world you would see if you'd
achieved it hear the sounds you might
hear might be Applause it might be the
sound of your car the sound of the ocean
lapping up against the front of your
beachfront property and feel the
feelings that you'll feel when you
achieve that success stronger the
feelings the more powerful the
experience will be and the easier it
will be for you to keep your goals and
your vision top of mind
dorsa said how do I believe my
visualization I visualize but I don't
really believe in it okay so are you
putting you in the picture with the
visualization
um because I want you to know that
there's not really any difference
between you walking around in this world
here this is for Law of Attraction no
difference to that or you imagining in
your mind there's no difference it
doesn't know any difference between the
two so if you're if you're visualizing
it Law of Attraction for Law of
Attraction this is something that you
you already have
and and so if you're not really
believing it it it just kind of means
you need to do it some more right and um
and and try and come up with some
scenarios that are really believable to
you like one of the things I would
always do to manifest and I don't know
why it just worked for me I defaulted to
this I would I would imagine I would
imagine telling somebody what I had
manifested that it had already
manifested so I would imagine those
phone calls I would imagine talking to a
friend I would imagine people saying you
know saying to me wow how did you get
that where did you get that so that was
really believable to me but if because
if you really want something then you're
going to want to share it with family
and friends and and so that really
worked incredibly well for me so maybe
that might work for you give that a try
everybody wants to enjoy a certain level
of wealth and success in life but so few
of us actually managed to create the
life of ease and abundant to still be
long for so why is that well one big
reason is because we don't cultivate a
healthy relationship with money we
develop beliefs attitudes and habits
about money in our youth that hold us
back from being able to generate wealth
and enjoy the Financial Freedom we
desire when we become adults now but the
good news is this once you're able to
identify these money roadblocks in your
own habits and behaviors you will be
able to overcome them once and for all
and finally be able to make more than
enough money to create the life of your
dreams
now the first roadblock to wealth
building is any self-limiting beliefs
you might have about money
perhaps as a child you were encouraged
to believe ideas like there's never
enough money to go around money doesn't
grow on trees wanting a lot of money is
selfish or even money is the root of all
evil now these childhood beliefs can
hinder your adult financial success if
you think the money is evil and that
wanting a lot of money is selfish you'll
be far more likely to avoid
opportunities to make more money and if
you think there's never enough money to
go around you'll be more likely to throw
your money away on frivolous purchases
because who knows when you'll ever get
another chance to do that again or buy
that again so if you want to Achieve
Financial Freedom the first thing you
need to do is some mindset work to
change the way you think about money now
here's a simple process to help you do
this first write down your limiting
belief or beliefs in your journal and
notebook for example your limiting
belief might be true artists don't care
about money
or I don't deserve to be wealthy so be
honest with yourself and identify
exactly what beliefs you have and how
they make you feel
and once you've written down your
negative belief write down all of the
reason why it's not actually true for
example many artists have achieved great
wealth in their lifetime think of
Picasso and David hockney and
singer-songwriters like Leonard Cohen
Paul McCartney and Kendrick Lamar and
the belief people are willing to pay
good money for art they love I know I've
spent twenty thousand dollars on one
piece of art and others have paid
Millions
now there's a new belief you can have I
am a good person who devotes so much of
my time to helping others and I deliver
a lot of value and I'm always ready to
do whatever it takes to get the job done
well
and then repeat these new beliefs as
affirmations to yourself several times a
day to shift your Consciousness around
money now you can also print them out
and post them on your bathroom mirror
your refrigerator next to your computer
anywhere where you're going to see them
on a regular basis and finally write a
positive turnaround statement that is
the opposite of your original belief it
is based on the reasoning you used in
step two for example instead of saying
two artists don't care about money say I
am a true artist my art is valuable and
I deserve to be paid good money for it
or instead of saying I don't deserve to
be wealthy you can say I am a good
person who works hard I care about
others and I deserve all the money I
desire
then repeat this new belief to yourself
several times a day for at least 30 days
this is a powerful way to create a much
more positive and powerful money mindset
the second big roadblock that holds
people back from making more money is
relying on a single limited source of
income for example if you have a job or
a career that doesn't pay much and
offers a little opportunity for growth
and that's your only source of income
you're going to find it a lot more
challenging to accumulate wealth so you
should either get the training you need
to be compensated for a higher paying
job or develop what we call multiple
streams of income to generate more
wealth for example let's say you're a
high school teacher you're going to find
it very challenging to become a
millionaire or a multi-millionaire if
you rely on your teacher's salary as
your only source of money that's not to
say you can't become a millionaire you
can choose to run a lucrative side
business in the summer or invest in
rental properties or learn how to manage
and invest your money extremely
effectively you can also join a network
marketing company and supplement your
income through direct selling and
rolling people in your downline in the
evenings and on the weekends there are
any numbers of ways you can grow wealth
and if you want Financial Freedom you
should explore every option and develop
a number of different income streams
that allow you to accumulate the wealth
you desire
now the third roadblock to wealth is
financial illiteracy by that I mean you
simply don't know what it takes to make
manage and grow your money and this is
essential information if you want to be
wealthy if you want to be a baker you
have to learn how to bake bread and
pastries you have to know exactly what
to do with the flour the salt the yeast
and so on and if you want to be
wealthier you have to learn how to make
manage and grow money you have to know
what to do with your paychecks your
bills your savings account your
Investments and so on now one of the
cornerstones of financial literacy is
knowing how to develop and stick to a
budget budgeting allows you to track
your money where it comes from where it
goes and how much you spend on all of
your monthly expenses this is super
important because it makes it easy for
you to identify areas where you're
spending too much so you can stop
overspending and invest that money in
your future instead you know most people
have no idea where their money goes they
don't know what their net wealth worth
is they don't know how much money they
need to retire so make sure you become
literate about financial things I also
want you to make sure you set weekly
monthly and yearly financial goals for
yourself in terms of how much you want
to earn spend and save and when you have
clear goals you are way more likely to
plan for them and Achieve them also
teach yourself the power of compound
interest if you make a loan or deposit
compound interest is the money added to
the original principle some of your
investment and rather than taking out
your interest in spending it you can see
simply let it be reinvested into the
account to earn even more interest is
the overall invested amount becomes
larger and larger gaining more and more
interest
now the fourth row block to wealth is
debt most of us in America and in many
other developed countries around the
world are carrying way too much debt and
the interest we pay on that debt not to
mention the pressure of all that money
needing to be paid back robs us of our
ability to generate lasting wealth so if
you want to be wealthy your first
priority should be to clear up your debt
and stop paying all that unnecessary
money and interest to Banks and credit
card companies you also need to learn
the difference between good debt and bad
debt good debt is debt that is taken on
to improve your future in some
significant way for example buying a
property that is sure to grow in value
over time
bad that on the other hand is death that
doesn't Advance your future in any way
but only cost you money for example over
expanding on your credit card or buying
a brand new car you can't afford and
then having to make high monthly
payments on it for years and years to
come now finally the fifth roadblock I
see holding people back from generating
more wealth is discomfort over asking
for money advice most of us are afraid
to ask others for advice around money we
feel like it's something we're supposed
to know and we're embarrassed to admit
that we don't and so we never reach out
and ask for the help we truly need but
you really need to get this it's okay to
ask for help there are people all around
you who will be more than happy to give
you the advice and counsel you need to
manage your money more effectively any
financial advisor at your bank would be
more than happy to meet with you review
your financial situation and give you
some free advice on how to grow your
will or if you know any wealthy people
at work or socially you can take them
out for lunch and ask them to give you
some tips on managing your money again
most people will be more than happy to
help and rather than looking down at you
they'll be impressed by the initiative
that you're showing ultimately the
ability to accumulate wealth is in your
hands anyone can make money no matter
where they are in life but it takes a
positive money mindset the willingness
and commitment to learning what you need
to know and then the action on your part
to make it happen
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to go
deeper into manifestation with Bruce
Lipton check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there and then
I'd start a process and it wouldn't
unfold and then it would irritate me
because it's like I gotta make it work I
gotta make it work ultimately I started
to recognize when things didn't work it
was possibly because there were better
ways to do it and I wasn't conscious of
it